[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sleep
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
all right now you should be able to hear
me all right man look look right now i
don't got my stream deck hooked up
so that's the reason you didn't hear me
with that but now let's
let's start that again let's let's back
up let's act like that didn't happen man
no one showed that to cognito
that never happened but what's going you
guys this is the attic show
on the iron lords podcast channel first
time it's been on here
you know we wanted to give you guys a
little bit more am i still muted
how am i still muted i'ma wait for you
guys to catch up for a couple seconds
kid are you there
am i still muted guys tell me if i'm
still muted
i can't hear you kid gotta get your
audio thing fixed okay it's all good
we wanted to give you guys more
entertainment and now it looks like my
camera isn't
going the way it should but that's okay
all right we want to give you guys more
entertainment
and i felt like when it comes to
my content sometimes you some of you
ended up on the iron lord
and the attic show anyway over on my
channel so we might as well
bring it and solid it and put it all in
one
subscription kid go to discord clearly
something's not right and with
with uh zoom just go to discord i'll be
in discord
let me leave that because something's
wrong with discord and i'm not
i'm not fighting with it right now today
is not today
but let's go to attic world that way a
kid can join
and everything be fine man everything be
fine
so what are you guys doing man like
obviously you know what we're talking
about we're going to talk about
the uh the the ps5 i i got one now
so we're going to talk about that and
you know my
experiences with it i finally got my
hands
on one thanks to kid smooth
let me send him this there we go and i
want
i want you i want to tell you guys my
experiences with it
addicts world the sequel addicts were
the secret we could say however you want
you can label it
however you want but right now i want to
you know really
broad you know get a kind of a feeling
that we want this i'm probably going to
reach out and get a little bit more
artwork made for the channel because
over on the attic
on the attic show man oh well on the
gaming attic channel i usually just did
these when i wanted to rant about
something i didn't take these any i
didn't take these seriously not not even
a little bit but now
since we are going into the point where
you know we're putting this on the
ironlord's podcast channel
i'll probably keep the
the starting soon thing because i want
that to kind of like synergize with the
iron lures podcast
but i'll probably get another overlay
made did kids sell you his ps4
yes can you hear me kid
hear me yes they should be able to hear
you now too talk one more time
a lot of background that's that's fine
you could just mute into your talk
into your talk want to speak just
tearing myself away from the outright
gotta go
work god man actually probably after
this me and kid are gonna play
the um uh the outriders man as you can
see
you guys know let me turn this
controller on
man this controller is really good
or is the the screen not working hold up
let me see if it was working the way
it's supposed to man
what you're trying to do uh hold up i
think it's working
do you guys see let me just mute this
make sure they can see what's going on
here
all right there we go there we go all
right so as you can see
the ps5 man i i got my hands on it
uh because of kid smooth you know shout
out to kid smooth and
i want to go over some of the things
that i have really seen with the ps5
and some of my mix with some of the
issues i have with it
you know kind of kind of go over exactly
down there
in the title screens what we're going to
go over and you know i'm going to ask
kid we're going to bounce back and forth
on this because
we have the same playstation but kid you
had your first
impressions you know i want to go over
mine and kind of compare them
and see maybe if you had them a couple
months ago because it's been
about about five months since they came
out
yeah so you know let's see if you know
we generally have the same
experience when it comes to you know i
don't know if there's any kind of post
updates or anything like that
the first thing i want to talk about so
you know the ps5 in general
the thing is huge it is bulky
and what i mean it's bulky means i don't
need any form of
you know if if i wanted to commit
violence to someone i don't need
anything i can use this as a blood start
object because this thing is huge
and i'm kind of curious why they made it
so big
like it's it's about 30 maybe 20 30
percent
taller than the ps uh than the xbox
series x
and it looks like i think the series x
might be a little bit
like lengthier d what do you think kid
we mean a month here another um like
what width-wise
uh if you it depends on how you like so
the the
ps5 in terms of like
it's definitely wider in terms of if you
were turning them like
like in terms of deepness with saying
that the ps5 is wider
it's definitely taller um but the ps5 is
actually in weight
lighter than the series x yeah series x
i think they're both heavy as hell like
they definitely both uh these consoles
were
were made uh with a lot of hardware
inside them so obviously you're gonna
see
they're gonna be a little bit heavy man
but like i what i like about the ps5
like aesthetic-wise it is not the same
size as the ps4 not even remotely the
same size vega
uh i would say this thing is
hold up let me get my camera i what i
will do for you guys hold up
hold up i can't
let me switch back to the i will take my
webcam
and i will show you guys the difference
uh hold up hold up let me bring this up
so i can see what i'm seeing
all right you guys ready let me
now look
at the size differences
like it's kind of crazy
the size differences like there
there's the height there i mean
i would say the playstation's a little
bit like slimmer
but the the playstation's definitely
taller like tremendously taller
and uh you know in the aesthetic wise
you know we'll go into that here in a
second let me put my camera back where
it was
all right there we go every
all right so you know i would say in
terms
of what is going on like
do you think aesthetics mean anything
kid like i i want your
your your honest example do you think
aesthetics when it comes to being in a
console
or being in a house do you think that
means anything
um i think it it did before not
much so now um where like
everything in the 2020s and
like this generation of like everything
like come on like we used to
go crazy over how smaller phones got and
then they got massively big again
um so no i don't i think aesthetics at
this point is overblown i don't think
it's a marketing um barrier anymore
um as it was like 10 15 years ago
i don't think it matters in the united
states as much but in other parts of the
the world i think it definitely matters
i think
so like us we're going to get it
regardless it doesn't matter what color
it is but
i tend i feel like a lot more like
setups or black there uh there's not a
lot of white setups like
black desks i'm talking about everything
like the size the color
i feel like not given the option for a
black one which is kind of weird because
the series s is white and the series x
is black
and then it's like the playstation 5 got
a little bit of both
so yeah that's the thing that plays it's
a two-tone it being two-tone is what
kind of throws it off
it has a lot of you it's technically
it's technically two-tone
plus because you got the white the black
and then you got the blue
leds to sort of like be that medium
yeah and i definitely i definitely agree
with you on that you know one thing that
i appreciate is like the the futuristic
color that's on the top of the
playstation like the blue
light i like that more i really would
like to have like where the fans are if
that green like kind of paint on the top
of the series x was
like a green led light yeah i think that
would have looked a lot better
um but you know as far as like what it
looks like it's huge we we've known this
for a while
i remember back like a year ago i was
telling kid on planet xbox
yo this ps5 got to be thick and remember
everyone argued with me everyone
i was like they're like no those those
virtual reality things they're off i'm
like
but that much because it was so it was
drastic
yeah but it is what it is man you know
at the end of the day
i don't think a console means anything
like what it looks like
i do think it has some form of play
across the countries and across the
world
but for the general a hardcore gamer
isn't going to care what it looks like
now the casuals might the casuals might
not buy something if it's
if it doesn't aesthetically go with
everything there is you're getting a
debs and follow i literally just got to
delve in fallout we
we ate fall guys i literally just got
one uh right before i got on the podcast
uh but you know we we will talk about
that later right now we talking about
the first impressions
uh let's let's let's move on to the
controller kid
you obviously you don't have it anymore
because i have it but um
do you think this is a a a
a build up from the original one
um yeah i mean i think it's a i like the
way it feels
um i think it's a i learned to like the
dual shock a little bit later in life
but uh the dual sense
yeah in every way better than the doll
shock for um
it's more it seems like a more mature
controller as in i feel like it's
finally proper for
my hands um i normally i play mostly on
xbox so the
flight the controller is more
comfortable with the exception of the
the the handles for some reason they
sharp off um
yeah yeah it kind of feels like like a
little bit of like a knife point like
it's not like a sharp but it's dull
like i feel like if it's kind of weird
like if you tap
on it like i'm tapping on it right now
like i can feel the vibration from all
the tech that's in it
so uh what did you feel about like you
know
the size comparison did you feel like
that was too much or that was just the
right
one for the controller from the four to
the
uh from the census uh the the
playstation
dual sets or whatever it's called the
door shock four versus are we talking
about the controllers all right yeah the
controllers
yeah yeah no i think um i feel like the
size is fine the the
the size of the ps5 controller the doll
sense
is a a good size i feel like it seems
um especially if you like especially if
you play on xbox a lot it feels
more like a proper uh controller
i like the weight of it doesn't feel
cheap the dualshock 4 felt
very light and like if you fling it for
like it'll just like snap it to a bunch
of pieces
the uh the dual system feels like
there's some quality behind it with some
weight in it
um cool controller it is a cool
controller like i i didn't really never
really had anything negative to say
about like the the dual sense
but in terms of like build in a way that
it feels in the hands
um it's it's comfortable i think it's
it's i don't think it's better than the
uh than the
the xbox controller i consider them all
the same the xbox one controller and the
xbox series x controller
they're slight differences but they're
the same controller but to me
they they kept evolving the xbox
controller it wasn't the same thing the
entire time
uh you know if you if you go back and
you find um
a day one yeah and then you compare it
to the to the day one xbox series x and
s controller
it's it's a night and day comparison
sure they look alike
but they're not the same controller you
know and it's mainly about
comfort that they they evolve because
for the most part i think we can all
agree
that the xbox controller is a is a solid
design they don't need to
change that like the design itself is
fine i think that made it a little
smaller
which is kind of funny because the
playstation's bigger and the xbox series
x control is a little smaller
but you know as far as the controller on
the xbox i felt like
they evolved it enough to where by the
time they got it to the
the ps5 all i mean the xbox series x all
they did was just put
grips on the top part like this part
right here that's all they did
and i feel like that that's that's a
fantastic change
and i feel like that the series action
controller is probably still my favorite
but now i i honestly feel like i could
play
shooters on this ps5 and i never could
do that
okay i got you got you got you um
did you play like anything like like any
like shooters with the um
the door since like tech i don't know if
i haven't yet like i don't think i
really own any like shooters on the on
the
on the console like i do have um
i do have this demon souls uh that's not
really a shooter
because to to me i cuz on the
playstation plus thing i believe they
have
one of the call of duty games so i might
try that later
and i wanted to stream
uh demon saw so i haven't even touched
that i've been playing a lot of uh
marvel spider-man miles morales and i
haven't even played a whole lot of that
but
what i could tell is you know they're
definitely taking advantage of the
system and
the game looks spectacular the the
loading screens are
really similar to the xbox you don't
really have like a huge difference in
what loads quicker what does it look
quicker the point is is they all load
fast
both of these systems are fantastic
consoles
it's just one is different size than the
other
and one's probably you know i honestly
feel like
the playstation will find its niche when
it's shorter
and when like the what's the word i'm
looking for when the
the slim model comes out i think it will
look more appealing
because it looks great it's just i feel
like it's too big
yeah and you know yeah and the
controller i think the controller is the
perfect
this dual sits is way better than the
the dualshock 4
like night and day better i don't really
care what did you feel about the
triggers
did you feel like that was like a huge
innovation that the internet wants you
to think it is
um personally for me um i thought it was
cool right like
i like i like astrobot was sort of like
really the perfect example that's the
only game i really
played that fully took advantage of the
of the dole sense
um but for me look at hearing about
other games that take advantage of it
like call of duty and stuff like that i
don't i don't think i would want to use
it for multiplayer
like shooters because i think to me i
feel like
even though they feel cool they will put
me at a disadvantage because at the end
of the day
when i'm in like in competitive mode i'm
not worried about how the trigger feels
or how
different the trigger should pull i'm
worried about getting that trigger that
shot off quick enough
um and if the controller is giving you
resistance that was my concern about it
so
i didn't play like games like astrobot
and spider-man uh spider-man gives you
some a little bit of uh
um uh features like when you're
doing a web sling and you feel like the
web pull a little bit um
but yeah no i feel like the feature is
dope i don't think to me
it didn't do anything whereas like if i
played the game on playstation
because remember i had obviously i owned
it at the same time as the xbox
when i went from playstation to xbox i
didn't feel like when i was went back to
xbox i was missing something in my hands
when i was playing on it
on xbox so to me it wasn't that big of a
deal but i know other people you know
they they look they put it as equivalent
as the visual upgrades but
personally for me it would to me it
wasn't that big of a deal i don't hate
it but
i i don't need it yeah i definitely
understand that
let's talk about the ui for a minute
obviously the xbox their direction was
we're going to keep the similar
uh the similar ui we're not going to
really innovate too much on it because
for the most part if you were on the
xbox platform you already got used to
the ui
and i i didn't think the ui on the xbox
was like horrible enough to have to
re-amp
vamp or anything i'd i've never liked
the playstation ui like not
one time have i ever liked it like you
you guys see like this line here on the
playstation 4
this line was apps and games and i used
to call it the wall of death
because they're like i get it they're
like oh there's
there's folders you could use folders i
don't even think there's folders on the
ps5 we're not going to get into that
but the the part that like blew my mind
is just like the fact that they're able
to change it from media to games i
really like that because
at the end of the day if you never want
to mess with media ever in any call
any shape form because people have smart
tvs people have extremely expensive tvs
that come with the apps
that are built for those ones then you
know obviously you wouldn't use your
playstation you know what i'm saying
so i like the fact that they make it to
where you can separate them and you
don't even have to
ever mess with medion on on playstation
whatsoever
because i i do feel like sometimes they
they like to integrate them a little too
much
and it does feel like right here because
when you when you launch it
it launches in the games one so clearly
on the game's playstation
they want you to see the games first
which it's it's a gaming console so
clearly
that is the point did you ever get
annoyed by the ps4 ui
kid honestly i haven't
spent much time on it like you know i
mean i would just go and
go through the game or and go to the
store a little bit um
the ps5 i mean even though they made
like they changed a little bit it's
still pretty much
the same it's just cleaner like there's
a like
you could tell it's a visual upgrade you
know to me in terms of what the ui but
i never had i didn't have any like
particular issues with the
playstation ui i didn't know i didn't
think personally i didn't think it was
any better than xboxes personally in my
personal opinion
um and that and this is my same uh like
opinion now
but um not but i didn't have any
personal issues with it i didn't think
it
did anything like wrong i just didn't
see what the big deal was
i just i never liked the playstation ui
i don't know why it's just something
that never really resonated for me now
this one's a little bit
better in some cases now if you guys
notice
when you press this button right here
one time this menu pops up
now to my knowledge someone in the chat
definitely correct me
but to my knowledge on xbox you just
have to hold the xbox button you could
power off the console is that correct
kid that's how that works right
correct you got a couple options to
power on playstation
you have to hold you you have to press
it then you have to go all the way to
power
which you know i can't see it because of
the obs
and then you have to turn off the
playstation 5. now look
is that a huge inconvenience no
but it is an inconvenience and i throw i
feel like
it because you just press it it pops up
so
what happens if you hold it okay holding
it
goes to the dashboard i believe so it's
just like
let me turn this thing off by holding
the button like
uh for some reason kid i thought you
used to be able to do that on
playstation but i was informed that you
couldn't
i'm just like that that's way too much
work to turn off a playstation
like you have to click like three
options you have to hold it go over to
the power button
and then another icon pops up like it's
like i said that is not a huge
inconvenience but i don't understand
why i have to go through so many hoops
just to turn off console
that's one of the knacks i had yeah
during my first week with it i had
trouble trying to turn it off directly
because the
my problem was i didn't want to just i
think if you push the power button and
just put it in sleep mode
um and i always avoid doing that because
that's when the reports of the
console being crashed or plagued with
like rest mode
issues so i didn't put the console on
rest mode at all i was trying to avoid
that
um so but when i was looking for how to
get it so i can just turn it off and
it i that that i found it that way and
then you know you can go to your like
your icon profile
and then you go log out and then you log
in and it go to the log out screen and
then there's a power button
on the bottom and then you hit turn off
um so those
those were a couple options i found yeah
it's it's not too crazy but
for if you're looking at just a turn off
button
um yeah it is for just a one step extra
that's not necessary
i mean i mean if you if you think about
with similar
devices now it's even hard to turn off
an iphone
you have to hold down uh um
because one button does too many actions
so you have to like
press hold it wait for the icon to come
up um
i think with the iphone you probably
gotta press two buttons at the same time
if i'm not mistaken
but but yeah no i'm that was my one of
my biggest gripes with the early on
now here's one for you kid all right the
ui
i didn't know they did this because i
got rid of the ps4
you know when i played live goes to
shashima it's the last game i played on
the playstation
i never really sent invites on parties
and stuff like that oh
for those of you that know it's here
somewhere man hold up give me one second
so i bought this this is the
the pulse headset i think that's what
this this suck is called
so i got this headset because i i wanted
to like play demon souls and stuff and
really good audio
uh and it's a good headset it's kind i
don't like the party chat
in the the playstation i don't like the
way it sounds
i don't know if you guys know this but
there's not open parties in playstation
it's all closed like you have to
physically invite people people can't
just join in and leave at their own
leisure like
like what the hell is sony thinking like
i i get it it's but like let me show you
okay so
you remember on his credit you remember
him so i'm in a party with him we we
chatting it up man it happened about an
hour and a half two hours
ago so i'm sitting here i'm like yo i
like this man it's so
i try i see jabari i was like yo
let me hit up jabari jabari never been
in a party with me let's go
so i sent japari an invite
kid it made me leave that one and sh and
start a new one
and i'm just like what so so i'm sitting
here i'm like okay maybe now i can send
critic one
and then when i when i went to sync
critic one it made me leave jabari's and
join critics
so i'm just like what is going on so
this is
this is how things go on the playstation
all right so i got it up
so in order to send people an invite on
the playstation
you have to go to the game base
send someone an invite so you send the
voice chat and then what it would do
is you go into it then after that you
have to
manually invite the other person now let
me figure out how to get to that system
i was on
and i'm just like i get it here it is
so pretty much like you'll send multiple
people the invite
and then now what will happen is those
people will get the invite
and it looks like it will kind of like
stay there so you can always join them
if those people are invited
but they no one can join by themselves
and i find that a little bit crazy to to
the fact that
playstation has made it to where you
can't just have an open
party like kind of like how xbox has and
discord where
you know kind of right now did i send
you an invite to join attic world
you know and that that's kind of crazy
to me
what do you feel about that yeah i was
in the party a couple of times
and i ran through some
hurdles like and funny because one one
of the first people i was in the party
with was
honest to critic and and
we were playing um destruction all-stars
and um
it was it was a weird like invitation
system um
that took place but i mean after you get
over it yeah they don't have it to a
place where i'm used to just going on
xbox and just hitting
x on the name and just in that sense the
party invite
and i and i'll just send it to whomever
you know or i'll start a party
have it open because you know they give
you the toggle option to open and close
it and if it's open people can just join
at their own leisure um
but yeah man the party thing is but but
i don't know how bad it was on ps4
because remember when i played on
playstation
i wasn't in parties all day like i said
it was
it was more so a long time when i was on
a playstation so
that even when i had the ps5 the first
time i got into a party
was when i was uh playing destruction
all-stars with uh jw and honest to
credit
i think obviously i like the power thing
that
that's a minor inconvenience i don't
really care about that you know
it's it's it's kind of like bizarre that
you have to go through that many options
to shut a console down but like to me
the party system is like is crazy low
quality like it's so hard to join and
like you know this mic i felt like it
had a okay
mic on it this headset but it didn't
feel like it was like
a quality quality now i've been told the
the new xbox mic
it's not that great either it's okay but
it's more about the
features and not necessarily like the
mic quality or anything like that
so you know i think they both need to
improve like if you get a call
if you get a mic do not buy any of these
mics
like even the xbox one you want to get a
better
third-party mic i feel like you know the
rigs 800 best heads i've ever had
problem is the mic is trash it
constantly messes up
so you know um find something with good
mic quality find something that's
comfortable too
this i can also say this is a
comfortable headset uh i've been told
that the new
xbox do you have this kit did you have
it
the pulse yeah the pulse no i didn't all
right so
i'm wondering if the pulse is about the
same like
like um cushion size is the new
xbox headset because i'm not getting
that until tomorrow i haven't really
compared them
uh to a whole degree yet so you know i
i don't really have an issue with it now
i do feel like the party system in
general can have an upgrade
especially in terms of the quality of
the audio i felt like the dude was way
too loud and maybe
and and what was funny is i tried to
turn it like a little bit more towards
the game volume
and then the game volume was over
talking him a little bit
so i feel like they need to improve on
that just a little bit
the the party's fine it's just some of
the some of the features and
how people sound needs to be improved a
little bit uh now
let's talk about the
uh just the games in general what was
the first game you played on playstation
five
um miles morales first game i played was
astro ball
um yeah i'm well okay it was i think
that's true i did play astro i booted up
straight after rob but i just kind of
just
played around with it until miles
morales uh finished installing but um
it was between like most of my game time
on ps5 went
to miles morales astrobot spider-man
remastered
uh i did a little bit of bug snacks and
i played a quite a bit of
sackboy and i also played godfall yo i
think
i think this dude i think astrobot might
be
the best like add-on game i've ever
played
like i know that sounds like crazy but
i've really enjoyed that game like i was
like obviously outriders is out what was
i playing kid cause
this is when outriders first dropped i
was playing
astro bot and and i enjoyed it i enjoy
the way that they use the controller
now i don't think this controller this
controller here
let let me just say this controller will
never be used like it is an astrobot
unless the people who made astro ball
make another one i don't expect that
kind of quality to ever be used like
that
but i do think they do show the
potential and i think that that means
something they show the potential
and i think that the the ways they can
use the controller is good and to my
knowledge
i'm pretty i was told that some of the
publishers and developers are going back
and they're restructuring how some of
their games work to
re uh to use the dual since and that
that's cool i feel like some of the
did you ever play until dawn kid yes i
do like you know how like the
the feature on the playstation
controllers where you can't move
yeah like yeah i remember at the very
end of until dawn
it caught me off surprise i was i was at
the very end where he's
like the light switch and he's about to
turn it off and on and
they're like don't move and i will never
for it's like i didn't breathe
i was like oh my god oh my god then i
accidentally moved
he made noise and he got himself killed
i probably got two people killed in
it until dawn because of that feature
i've never liked that feature if i know
it's coming on i'll literally just put
the controller down
and let it just sit still i don't i i
don't because it feels like
it's kind of gimmicky where you're not
moving
but it like it it's like it fills the
heat off your hand and it feels like
it's moving you know what i'm saying
yeah and i i get that but it's just like
i feel like they could have did away
with that
showing love to my homie look
okay i cognito for years has been
getting onto me over my health he says i
need to start eating better
what's the point in building a brand and
helping build iop and helping build
gaming addict
if i die in five years so so
i've been going to the gym and today i
messaged cognito i was like
so i eat kfc and i bake chicken and he's
like
oh so i guess he was a little bit you
know he's obviously in here
uh gloating that i eat baked chicken
baked chicken was actually lit i ain't
gonna lie i like baked chicken
i'm okay with the baked chicken stuff
now i i think
me when it comes to my health it's not
necessarily about stuff you know i won't
eat it's stuff that was more convenient
to get
quicker you know what i'm saying but you
know i'm gonna take a little bit more
time on that but we're going to go away
from my health man because
you know let's let's focus a little bit
more on playstation all right
you so you had demon souls but did you
even try play it
nope you didn't even you didn't even put
it in
nope damn you know um i i enjoy
i enjoy demonstrations i haven't played
a whole lot of it i play like
the first level when i let the original
do uh the first boss kill me
because i kind of want to stream that
game you know what i'm saying so but you
know
one thing i love about playstation that
xbox
lacks is this game right here it's
called fall guys the ultimate knockout
we're supposed to be getting it
soon kid but you know how i love i love
that game i was playing it earlier
and i was just hit uh you know talking
stuff with uh honest critic
and i i would and i'm just sitting here
not even thinking i'm just literally
brain playing this game you know what
i'm saying and
it just says winner and i was like oh i
i literally just
i just won a whole game i won the whole
game wasn't thinking
that this is probably one of the best
party games you can ever play you know
it's up to four people
definitely try this game if you guys
haven't and when and when it comes to
xbox
i really hope this is this isn't game
pass because i think this game is a
phenomenal game and i think the
developers deserve all the money they
can
and you know it's definitely one of the
reasons i love having a playstation
now there's this game here called
persona 5.
i think i'm waiting for this game to hit
game pass
because my issue with this game is i've
started this game
three damn times and i've still have
never beat it
and now i didn't know how
stupid the cr the save file stuff is on
playstation
i thought because what i did right
before i left playstation
i went to playstation plus and i thought
you know they would just automatically
update all my stuff to the cloud you
know what i'm saying
and then when i got the ps5 i would just
you know renew get back to playstation
plus and i would have access to them
nope you gotta do a bunch of uh nonsense
man
and some of them didn't work um you know
i do know that games like final fantasy
10 it's got like a natural one
so i was able to keep it and you know
i i i think i was able to let me load it
up what should i be there if it's not
there i'm gonna be upset
on live live tv well it's not a tv but
you know what i'm saying
i feel like they need to why why do we
attack microsoft for keeping games
behind
uh you know free to play games behind
all which we should
we should definitely attack anyone
that's trying to make you pay
to play free to play games but i feel
like we should have that same energy
for sony that are trying to put cloud
saves behind the wall
like we need to be more vocal about that
that's that's bull we need to get that
gone
well do you do you think that's right
kid like i personally think that is
that's crazy that they're charging you
just to keep your
your load saves on a cloud
yeah um that's where i kind of lost um
where i
like okay this is the value of having
playstation plus because
uh for my last two years on
ps4 i didn't renew my ps plus because i
wasn't downloading
plus games like that and i wasn't
playing any games online no multiplayer
games on playstation so
when i was doing my spider-mans and the
last of us and other stuff i just kind
of forgot
that the whole cloud save thing was you
know on the back of playstation plus
so when when i came to ps5 i went and
i'm sitting there trying to download
because at the time of ps5 came out
i actually bought ps plus i was like all
right i'm gonna do it because they got
the ps plus collection
and i you know i grabbed my games and i
recently played the last was part two
and i started go suzushima and day's
gone
so i was like yeah i'll buy playstation
plus so i did that
i downloaded these games and i'm trying
to download my save files for all these
games and i realized like there's
nothing to download because
they weren't uploading to the cloud
anyway because i wasn't playing for ps
plus
so i was like oh okay well that's my
fault
so but yeah it it it's a problem it does
it's something that doesn't get enough
uh doesn't that get get enough attention
um the crazy
part about it too kid is like there was
none of that
like when i went from the xbox one to
the xbox series x
it was literally just i put that in i
load that game up and the saves there
there was no headaches there was no like
hiccups you know
i could literally download something and
play immediately
and i feel like sony definitely dropped
the ball on that like
that needs to be more uh be a lot easier
than it is now
yeah really um yeah with the
obviously with xbox you don't you don't
even have to you don't have to manually
do anything you don't have to manually
download to save or anything like that
it just it just works as intended so
that that's the thing
just to get used to um but i made that
mistakes
on playstation uh a couple of times so
that's the reason why i couldn't recall
my trophies
for spider-man remastered like everybody
else was and um
and why i had to start ghost tsushima
days gone
even the last of us all from the
beginning again even though i
played and beaten those games on live
stream i i might say
i had no save file on ps45 obviously so
but i think uh well what is um what's
that other game the
the other little game the like the
platformer the playstation has um
exactly sackboy was that any good i
don't have that
i i think i don't have anything bad to
say about it i thought it was
decent looks good um but it just didn't
hold me i played a lot of it though too
but um i don't think it's bad like i
don't think it's a bad game i think it's
it's all right
that's good i feel like playstation
definitely gives like they have a lot of
different genres
when it turns to what type of games they
go i do think microsoft
now with the the studios that they
currently own
i think they're more diverse than
playstation currently is would you agree
to that or do you disagree with that
um we got to see when their games come
out but i do yeah i think they have a
with
obviously 23 studios and there's
definitely some diversity
there um i just think even not even with
their first party but
games that they've been you know
partnering it the the people that
they've been recruiting for idea xbox
um a whole lot of diversity a lot of
different things um
and a lot of things i don't even know if
i would personally be um interested in
myself but um it was something that
um they lacked during their their early
early days but when you look at um
playstation
um and we if we're talking exclusively
like first party
yeah xbox easily more diverse even right
now with their lack of
games the games that they do have are
all different variants none of them are
alike
and i do think that xbox
i think they're going to to have a more
diverse library
but i do think playstation is going to
have the better overall games
and it and it's like i said we're going
to have to see you know some of these
higher quality
microsoft studios what exactly they
produce but as far as like i don't think
they're ever going to make anything
i had issues with last of us part two
but it was a very
high quality game i had issues with
you know i mean that's pretty much all i
actually really liked the original last
of us
i liked god of war phenomenal game i had
some issues with it
i felt like sometimes playing god of war
the camera would get a little bit in the
uh
in the way especially when you're
fighting some of the valkyries but
besides that i felt like it was a
phenomenal game and
i do feel like microsoft is has a better
edge
and they and they're working their way
to have that kind of quality games
but i don't think they're going to have
it for a while probably not this
generation maybe
you know we have to see how games like
the initiative do because they've been
hiring really high when it comes to
stuff like that what to say how fab was
a playground because
uh you know playground is a 90 plus
metacritic score game sure those are
sports games
we're not sports games but racing games
but i do feel like
it's not necessarily because they're in
the racing genre they they just made
the game that fits that genre the best
and i don't i don't think
that that kind of law no logic is going
to go out the door
i think they're going to clearly they've
been hiring people to make a type of
game like
fable and i think they're going to have
similar quality
you know we'll have to see how it
happens when it first comes out but
a lot of these people think a lot of
these devs are one-trick ponies a lot of
these devs switch back and forth from
completely different genres
yeah they're all pretty capable of doing
stuff especially some of the
higher up people uh but you know as far
as the playstation
i think it's got a good symmetry it's
like the only real knack i have
the biggest one i have is the party
system sony got to
fix that yesterday but you know
i just use discord and xbox i'll join
playstation parties when
you know people don't want to go to
discord but i prefer not to use the
party system on the playstation
i feel like it's it's crazy the way they
do it like
you you should just be able to start a
party and send invites you shouldn't
have to go through all these hoops but
that's just me
that's how it is on the xbox i guess
it's because i'm used to that on the
xbox and not necessarily
if it's bad i'm just used to how the
xbox does it and that's not really the
playstation's fault i still think that
they misjudged and whoever decided to
change the party system that way should
probably lose their job
but that's besides the fact i i think
the console's too big
but you know again does that really
matter not really but
i do think aesthetically there are some
people that are really going to be
you know open up to what a console looks
like
now uh what i want you guys to do is i
want you put in the chat
your issues with the playstation and me
and kid are going to see if we agree
with you
and i don't think that some of these
people because i've been seeing some of
the people
comment on it someone said we're crying
too much uh all i really did was
criticize the the party system and the
way
uh and how big it is i guess that's
crying too much kid we crying too much
so like you could literally i could tell
people god of war is a 10 out of 10.
and then i say anything else and people
don't hear that i literally just praise
playstation with god of war god awards
the best game if not the second best
game that came out last year
yeah and and ghost shashima is leaving
or in front of her right behind it
like probably my top 10 games the last
generation probably six of them were
playstation games
and you know that at the end of the day
that's what christ for the most is
you want good games and playstation will
give you that game and as long as
they're able to give you that issue
then as long as they're able to give you
those games it will always be a relevant
console
i think next week on the attic show i'm
going to break
like the future of both consoles down a
little bit more i don't know exactly
what i'm going to do on that i'm trying
to get some people in line
i will talk about that a little later
someone said my issues i can't get one
look man if it wasn't for kid look look
shout out to kid
kid could have easily i'd be like get
give me a g
homie give me a g okay but he did he
sold it to me for retail price
uh and i really appreciate it storage
manage management is rubbish
i didn't really talk about that a lot
because i don't as you can see a lot of
these games i have downloaded are not
that big
so i don't think i'll go through the the
the storage
and you know games like last of us part
two have already beat so
i don't really got no issue with fly
status part two i just want to see how
it looked on the ps5 i'll probably
delete it later
uh someone said ps5 needs quick resume
and better
ui navigation do you agree with that kid
quick resuming uh uh i mean
it would be i guess it would be nice to
have i mean i know you can quick resume
sort of one game at a time if i'm not
mistaken or you could jump through it
from the cards
uh you know those activity cards at the
bottom um that they
for the for you to jump into a
particular part of the game
uh so you can like hurry up and get the
trophy or do the challenges
but yeah um quick resume would be a nice
touch um
it's an underrated feature that doesn't
really give the much attention
um i'm so used to it on xbox i forget it
it's doing it it's just like oh
oh this is where i left off um and what
was the other thing he said
he said uh let me look for he said quick
resume and better ui navigation
better ui navigation yeah even though
all right so
i give playstation credit for it being
all right i turn on the playstation this
is new this is something
i'm i'm playing on a different system
than the ps4 i do give it credit for
that
but it doesn't mean that it's actually
better
um it's just it's just new they have a
new ui clean
ui and stuff but it is confusing and you
know the older you get man the lot
a lot less time you want to spit in the
menus looking for [ __ ] um
my apologies looking for stuff um
whereas the xbox even though i was like
man i wish they would have like done
something to make to tell me yo this is
a new xbox
i kind of just got to work very easily
it was just like okay
uh let me just change the background to
something more because
since the xbox has dynamic backgrounds
now and where playstation
4 had dynamic backgrounds ps5 don't um
it's weird to me i don't know i don't
know if you noticed that though
yeah i think in a lot of ways
playstation backpedaled in this and i
think what it was because they made a
new ui
and if you think about it like this
i think they can make better dynamic uh
themes with this new one
yeah they can if they because they have
more screen to work with
but i don't i don't know if like the the
console itself was built for it you know
what i'm saying like
maybe they have to go and reprogram it
maybe they had to rush the ui because
the consoles were coming quicker than
they thought they were
and they just had to get this out there
but that's just me making assumptions i
don't know anything
uh you know it's actually really hard to
get inside information on playstation
like really hard to get stuff because
play playstation don't really talk to a
whole lot of people they keep a lot of
stuff
on the down low so it's hard to you know
really find out anything about what's
going on
in the background uh no someone said no
real browser integrated way to
authenticate an internet connection
there are tricks for this but not with
every connection
so i'm assuming first off he's saying no
real browser which is funny because i
remember in the settings somewhere
because i was looking how to share game
games on here there was an actual tab
dedicated to a
web browser yeah but there's not a web
browser on here i guess
that that's kind of weird uh and i guess
what he's talking about here he's
talking about
you know on xbox when you like test or
you test a or you click details in the
internet thing
yeah where it tells you like packet loss
etc etc
yeah i don't think that's on here that's
the way they're making it seem i don't
think that's all
oh wait wait you can't test your
internet speed you should be able to do
that right oh let's see
i mean i wouldn't do that now because it
will reveal like your ip and all that
other stuff so i don't care
i'm looking at all right so let's see
it does test the the download and upload
i don't know exactly what you uh you
meant by that like did you mean like
certain like more details
i'm kind of curious what you meant by
that definitely put that in the comment
section
when um you're ready to uh to talk about
that because i don't know what he meant
by that
but um you know i didn't see it i saw
it looked like it gave you the download
speed and upload speed uh so okay so
here's another one
no easy way to turn off the system party
chat search engine for games sometimes
when the game file gets corrupted for no
reason
um i don't know what that means uh so i
guess he's saying there's no
easy way to turn off the system we went
over that uh the party system
uh the party chat we went over that too
search engine for games sometimes
like you press y here's the search
engine like
is there so like do you want like like
where you can
like filter it through like publishers
and developers i'm kind of curious what
you mean by that
hit the search button on your thing um
is it triangle or you just have to go up
and
it's trying hit triangle and then type
in like a game
or something that that would be on
playstations
i hate this touch bad thing you get to
use a touchpad
no like it's the touchpad always be like
registering like i'm trying to use it
all right so i mean it looks like it's
going to
ah i mean here here's godfall so
i mean i feel like it's working fine
like yeah then again
he might be talking about something like
we don't really know like
i can't he can't get all his words off
in that so he's probably well
i'll tell you this like for example on
xbox if you hit search you can search
for
literally anything and it'll pop up
whether it be an app
that's on the box or you know a game or
something
i think when they they they want you to
search them individually
like this is the media one so you
probably put like netflix
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah which i'm okay
with that like
overall search and i hate that sometimes
i feel like
i if i want to just look at games i
should be able to just look up games on
xbox
and they kind of yeah but if you ask me
if you did it from like the the the
your home page if you want to go with
the games and then look up you could go
to the store and look up exclusively
games but if you did it from your home
page
that's the system for everything uh
that's one found on
xbox okay um someone said
and when the game file gets corrupt for
no reason uh i do think i've seen
multiple people complain about that that
the
the game just gets corrupted for no
reason
yeah i've heard about uh i've heard
about that i don't know exactly like
how serious or widespread that is but i
do know that some people are having
issues with that
someone said the last of us two needs a
60 frame patch uh playstation 5 a lot of
places need 60 frame patches
uh playstationes to get uh
on top of things when it comes to this
backwards compatibility stuff
because xbox is destroying them
when it comes to backwards compatibility
or pretty much how a game performs in
general
like there's multiple games right now
that you cannot
uh that that didn't that are only
running good on xbox and not playstation
i think i mean you know obviously some
of the bethesda games but you'll give
them a pass on that
they can't control some of that now
maybe microsoft's blocking that
but i don't think they would uh because
you know they've been very open with
updating stuff because what do you mean
no i'm just saying like
i don't know if microsoft behind closed
doors are not willing to give
uh sony the patch for older games i
don't think that's happening
i think we would um because bethesda's
aren't even going back to those games
that's the xbox
eternal team is doing that themselves
but
i was just saying but that's the games
like i don't know because they're going
they're coming out with a natural a
next-gen upgrade to elder scrolls
online that's what i mean that's what i
mean is that xbox only
no no that's not xbox only i'm just
saying like other games like that i
don't know
necessarily they're trying to do
anything uh the way i've
been described is xbox like anything
that's old
you know microsoft is 100 down if
something comes out
and it's on and it's on playstation
already they're going to update the
playstation one too they're not just
going to do
xbox they're going to update them both
yeah
now games like overwatch that's not on
playstation
the next gen update to my knowledge
that's only on xbox
and that's because microsoft built their
whole system
around around backwards compatibility
like i don't know exactly how
we'd have to get someone like jason
ronald because he has a lot more
information
obviously because he's you know lead of
that whole team
uh so the way it's been described to me
is like
that was one of the key points that they
they built the whole system for
is that they always wanted to make sure
that backwards compatible games
work and they always wanted to leave
doors to make them better
yeah so you know i think sony needs to
find a way to fix that because they
looking a little
a little suspect a little shady when it
comes to stuff like that but
you know the advantage xbox has like um
is fps boost that's not really like a
developer
thing and that's really no a handful of
bethesda games got it because they're
xbox now but that was just more so
that's permission they don't have to get
anymore to do bethesda games since they
own them now uh to fps boost
those so they're not going to boost them
they're not going to go and boost those
on play that's up to
bethesda themselves to go back and then
make a a
native enhancement but then again if
they're going to play then they'll have
to go back and do it for
xbox because then it won't um it will be
better
on playstation because they're doing the
actual enhancement upgrade versus xbox
just
sort of yeah i agree in the game itself
all right so
someone said i don't like that
uh i actually don't like the new
controller that much it slips out of my
hands
weird shaped it is kind of weird shape
but it fits in my hand better in general
because maybe i have big hands i don't
know uh if if the individual that said
that doesn't have big hands
uh i do know that one of my friends she
said that she doesn't like the
controller because it's too
it's too big for her now like she she uh
you know she has small hands so when it
comes to something like that it's hard
for her to really use it effectively
so maybe sony because um you know the
doors
the dual shock i always felt was too
small
but the dual sense i feel is just
perfect for me but
i i'm a big person so i have big hands
so that would make sense
i'm sure there's a lot of smaller people
that they ain't fill in this controller
um anything you have to say about that
no i mean like in terms of the con
controller i think i i always thought it
was an upgrade over the dual shock 4.
yeah i do too i do too uh someone said
controller b
white's the only biggest con of it i i
like the controller man i like the
controller um
i think they need to be a little bit
more open like microsoft is to making
different versions of controllers
i know people like to use that as a joke
for some reason acting like they're the
same department when they're not
but i do feel like you know my sony
needs more variety of controllers in
general
yeah i mean i i don't know how much more
money it costs to produce um
playstations controllers since they got
you know that stuff where's xbox
if you look at them they're sort of i
don't want to say they're oh let me see
all right so after a while i used to
think all right they're just putting a
new face on them right
that is just just a painted face but
then again it's not actually because the
the buttons um change um different color
to led light changes
um behind the um guide button um the
thing that
bugs me about the xbox um this new
series controller is the two-tone like
the white back
that's what makes it looks lazy but
like it's like the the black you have
the black shoulder buttons
and then you get the white back and then
it's the blue face i would i want the
whole controller to be like
that be that red yeah i want to know i
want the whole controller
uh to be that solid new color not just
the front facing you know
um because the white you know what i
mean it's gonna get dirty back here so
you turn that controller around because
you see the dirt and [ __ ] all right so
um i definitely understand that i feel
like
do you think sony needs their own
version of that of that program that
lets people that lets people design
their own controller like
color-wise and everything for more of a
price nope because
playstation fans don't like controllers
no i don't think i don't think it's
necessary for them i think um i don't
even think it was necessary
xbox but xbox had this thing with custom
control remember that one year they had
like
so many different colors and custom
controllers released remember how they
they had all those different colors in
that in that in that bowl
in that one yeah that one inside x5
yeah yeah all right so we don't got two
any of these uh he said authenticating
an internet connection like when you're
at a hotel or in my case a truck stop
uh so i guess it's like an individual
like a truck driver that's like saying
like
he wants better internet uh features
when
he has wi-fi six though shouldn't be
able to like i don't think a lot of
people have wi-fi sick so i don't know
um you know i don't know does that does
the xbox have that fire start
yeah i mean i don't know if you have an
xbox like i'm curious if it does
uh someone said if i start texting the
game sometimes uh it finds another game
when i put in the exact name um
i don't know are we talking about like
games with similar names like call of
duty
i think that would be funny but uh
yeah i've never seen that he would have
to tell me what actual game it is so
i'd look it up to see if it does it
still um it's the best uh
it's the way backwards compatibility
works sony can't do it unless they make
a ps5 version
that's what you were saying earlier kid
ps5 boost can be done without the devs
doing it that's incorrect
xbox is doing fbs boost without
permission from devs
so i think sony just can't even if they
wanted to
i don't know if they weren't do that
they were doing it without the
permission of devs i feel like they
still had
you know their permission to some point
i don't think they would work on
someone's other
products without at least informing them
if they're doing it
i don't know though i'm not in that
thing i got big hands as well it is a
nice touch for me
and all a uniform color scheme i think
that's we were talking about where
everything's black red
green and not just like certain parts of
the controller is that what you talk
about
yeah all right so you know we're gonna
go ahead
and uh you know give our final thoughts
and get out of here i'm gonna get mine
first and then uh you know give it to
kid i think it's a solid system i think
it's too big like i said i think the
party system needs to be fixed
uh you know the the the being able to
shut off the console
i don't think that's a huge issue but i
think it is an inconvenience
it's okay to have something as an
inconvenience but still do it you know i
work is an inconvenience but i still got
to do it but you know
i think that's that's okay i you know
the ui in general
i think i think it could look some way
different you know
not necessarily i i don't know like i
like how they separated it
but i do feel like the folders need to
get in here they need to be
a little bit more quicker when it comes
to stuff that was in the ps4 getting in
the ps5 there's no reason why we should
have a ps5
that is lacking ps4 features we're
supposed to go forward not backwards
but you know controllers good thing
controllers phenomenal
best thing about the upgrade besides
obviously the hardware upgrade
is the control is lit and i i love it
it's definitely a great controller
what is your assumption what is your
final thoughts on the playstation
kid when you get another playstation
because i know you don't have a
playstation
yeah um with the honestly the ps5 is a
it's a fine console it's futuristic
looking i do like even though it's big
as hell
it is a futuristic looking console i
like that it feels new
and looks new and looks like very shiny
it definitely
has some games to like to show off on
your new tv
um it is it's a cool um um
platform to have so i really don't have
anything negative the only issues i do
personally have with it myself
i think they need to hurry up and uh
incorporate vrr support
um because firestarter saying
i know what he's talking about you know
how like when you connect something
like a mcdonald's wi-fi tell it it has
like an internet browser that pops up
and says
do you agree to these things you're not
going to hack with our wi-fi apparently
playstation doesn't do that now
you know that's what firestart says
that's crazy so that means like like
like people that are on the tr like
truck drivers and stuff can't even use a
go online and stuff that that yeah they
need to fix that
so continue what you're saying because
yeah i think i do need to hurry up and
get support for vr
they really need to do support for um
store expansion believe it or not
um i actually ran out of um memory on my
um playstation
um but i didn't sweat it because i
wasn't really playing um playing it i
just had the games that i just kind of
had installed just in case um so they
need to hurry up and um do that for that
ssd expansion
um and i think uh they really got to do
something about this whole cloud save
or this their their cross buying program
for you that i think that needs to
kind of they got to sort that out and
make that easier for people
um otherwise it's a console to find
console
um yeah it's definitely a good console i
i enjoyed using it you know
obviously still my xbox will be my
primary place to play stuff
i thought i was going to lose you to
playstation
you you know better you need to stop
that nonsense but
you know i enjoyed uh trucker addict
defending his brethren
look man i will give you chris jones
says wi-fi six
you know maybe the next couple years
wi-fi six only be on on playstation will
make a difference and i think that is a
good possibility
because i have been told wi-fi six is a
huge you know
improvement from the wi-fi's that we use
currently but we'll have to see
you know we'll have to see exactly how
that works but you know definitely
appreciate everyone for coming out here
for uh the first attic show on the iop
channel
i think me and kid are going over and
play the out of worlds i think that's
what we're about to do and
uh writers outriders
dude you're fine you're fine uh but i
appreciate it from coming by man we're
about to close this up
uh until next time definitely be sure to
check tomorrow
at 5 00 p.m we're going to be having
um calamari already on he is going to
uh you know a lot of people you know
speculation with
colin because uh some people don't like
some of the aspects that he does on
twitter and it's like i said man
i get it politics is a rough thing for
everyone but we're
talking about gaming this is nothing to
do political uh
what what colin's political opinion and
political out view should have nothing
to do with how you feel about him
as someone that writes and covers games
uh he
he's been in this industry for years uh
i don't
ask you to like the man uh but i ask you
to respect him because he's on our
platform
and you know we're gonna have a good
time we have a lot of good playstation
topics the topic's already in there
uh you know we we give everyone a voice
it doesn't matter who you are in the
industry
uh we give everyone a voice and we want
to thank everyone for coming tomorrow uh
who comes tomorrow and listens to the
show
it's 5 p.m eastern and you know we'll
see you guys later this gaming addict
uh anything tell them where they catch
you kid tell them what to catch you i
almost forgot to let you
i'm so used to doing these by myself i
forgot to let you give your plug
that find me on youtube uh
kids move i just dropped a video
yesterday showing you how
you know i've successfully beat you know
malik
and the outriders in less than two
minutes also got um uh
you know let's talk games podcast
finally up after some copyright
ps and then uh what else did i drop i
feel like i dropped my oh i sold my ps5
video it was a
video so uh yeah that that video did
pretty good too didn't it
yeah yeah i did thank you for making
that happen
maybe that will cover some uh some extra
money on top of the money i gave you
all right but i appreciate everyone
coming through like i said be there
tomorrow iop
5 p.m eastern we're going to be we're
going to be talking a lot of good
actually real quick before we close up i
will tell you the topics real quick
uh they're actually really good topics
especially someone like colin because he
he he's so big in the sony industry that
it's really nice that we have a lot of
you know
playstation topics that we could talk to
him about so obviously we had the mlb
show going to game pass and we have the
ps
game preservation and obviously we're
going to stink a little bit of stuff
like that so you know we're going to be
really expanding that uh going over
exactly how he feels
where sony is right now you know he is a
game developer we're going to go over
exactly you know uh
how he feels about the vita cutting
support because he was making gains for
the vita it's gonna be a good show it's
gonna be good time definitely go over
there
uh hit that hit that bell icon man so
you're
informed when we go live tomorrow but
this is gaming